[Musik]
schönen guten Abend nach der
beschlossenen Steuersenkung in Thüringen
ist die Aufregung groß groß deswegen
weil die oppositionelle CDU das Gesetz
im Landtag auch mit Stimmen der
Rechtsextremen AFD durchdrückte viele
kritisieren das jetzt als gefährlichen
Dammbruch und fragen was vom Versprechen
übrig ist nicht mit der AFD
zusammenzuarbeiten dort erfährt mit den
Reaktionen
es ist dieses Bild im Thüringer Landtag
das auch am Tag danach für eine heftige
Debatte sorgt CDU und FDP Stimmen
gemeinsam mit der AFD unter Björn höcke
für die Senkung der Grund derwerbssteuer
ein Gesetz verabschiedet von der
Opposition mit der Thüringer AFD die vom
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft wird es
ist eine Einzigartigkeit in der
Parlamentsgeschichte in Deutschland so
viel Macht hatte die AFD noch nie wie
ihr die CDU in Thüringen gestern
zugestanden hat wenn das Schule macht
was gestern im Erfurter Landtag passiert
ist dann ist der Parlamentarismus in
Deutschland ab diesem Tag ein anderer
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz äußert sich
heute mit Verweis auf Termine nicht zur
gestrigen Entscheidung sein
Generalsekretär Carsten Linnemann
erklärt uns geht es um die richtigen
Weichenstellungen für unser Land und
nicht um taktisches Geplänkel denn damit
entlasten wir gerade junge Familien und
kurbeln die Wirtschaft an
doch es gibt doch Kritik aus der CDU zum
gemeinsamen Vorgehen mit der AFD
ich halte es für eine schwerwiegende
Fehlentscheidung die dort getroffen
worden ist für mich gilt unten
umstößlich das ist jegliche Form der es
Zusammenwirkens mit der AFD nicht geben
darf gerade in Thüringen eine
rechtsextreme Partei es sei ein Antrag
der CDU-Fraktion im Thüringer Landtag
gewiesen hatte FDP-Chef Lindner heute
betont auch die Liberalen Abgeordneten
hatten dort gemeinsam mit der AFD
gestimmt
afd-chefin Alice Weidel erklärte
Friedrich Merz Brandmauer sei Geschichte
und Thüringen erst der Anfang
gehen wir nach Berlin Theo colll welches
Dilemma löst diese Thüringer
Entscheidung jetzt aus also das eine
Dilemma ist die zutage tretende innere
Spaltung der CDU in dieser Frage man
werde handlungsunfähig sagen die einen
wenn man sich nur daran orientiert ist
die AFD den eigenen Vorschlägen nicht
zustimmen für die anderen die eben
gehört bei Daniel Günther muss jegliche
mithilfe der AFD für Mehrheitsfindung
ausgeschlossen bleiben und die anderen
Parteien die stehen vor der
Herausforderung oder dem Dilemma künftig
auch mit der Opposition Mehrheiten zu
organisieren dafür aber ohne die AFD
bisher bleiben die Parteien lieber bei
ihren alten ablehnungsreflexen und
empören sich dann hinterher das aber
wird politisch nicht mehr ausreichen
denn nicht nur in Thüringen sondern auch
in Sachsen und Brandenburg kommt die AFD
mittlerweile ja in den Umfragen auf über
30 %. vielen Dank Theo und Grüße nach
Berlin und Umfragen ist ein gutes
Stichwort bundesweit ist die AFD im
Moment jedenfalls deutlich zweitstärkste
Partei einem Land das ergibt sich aus
den neuesten um Fragezeichen des ZDF
politbarometers bei der Sonntagsfrage
kommt die SPD nur noch auf 17 % - 2
gegenüber dem Vormonat die Union bleibt
unverändert bei 26 die Grünen +1 auf
jetzt 16 Prozent FDP -1 6 Prozent die
AFD klettert um Prozent ein Prozentpunkt
auf 21 also neuer Höchstwert für die
Partei und die Linke steht unverändert
bei 5 Freie Wähler bei 3%
. jetzt nach Libyen im
Katastrophengebiet sind die Menschen
dringend auf internationale
Unterstützung angewiesen gestern ist
eine erste deutsche Hilfslieferung vom
THW eingetroffen
Rettungstrupps suchen weiter nach
Überlebenden einige Gebieter sind nach
wie vor überflutet laut rotem Halbmond
kamen mindestens 11.300 Menschen ums
Leben die Opferzahl könnte weitaus höher
liegen tausende werden noch vermisst
mehr Milliarden damit die Bahn pünktlich
kommt das Verkehrsministerium möchte
trotz angespannter Haushaltslage 40
Milliarden Euro zusätzlich locker machen
um bis 20 30 Schienen zu sanieren
reisende müssen mit monatelangen
Sperrungen und langen Umleitungen
rechnen
seit fünf Jahren kämpfen die Aktivisten
von Fridays for future für mehr
Klimaschutz jetzt riefen sie wieder zum
globalen klimastreik mit einem Bild vom
Nordpol läuteten 40 Klimaforscher in der
Arktis diesen Protesttag ein auch in
Asien wie hier auf den Philippinen
gingen die Menschen auf die Straßen in
Deutschland waren in rund 250 Orten
Proteste geplant die größten in Berlin
Hamburg und München die Martin Niessen
jetzt berichtet
sie gingen wieder auf die Straße mehrere
10.000 Menschen in ganz Deutschland
folgten heute dem Aufruf von Fridays for
future der unterstützt wurde von einem
Bündnis aus Naturschutzverbänden
Gewerkschaften und Kirchen heute machen
wir mit der breiten Allianz
verspielt werden das klima-gesetz muss
verschärft werden und endlich muss das
Klima Geld kommen wir haben die guten
Lösungen und die guten Konzepte damit
wir aus den Krisen rauskommen aber die
Regierung ja muss aufhören zu blockieren
zuletzt hatten allerdings radikalere
Gruppierungen wie extinischen Rebellion
oder letzte Generation viel
Aufmerksamkeit aber auch Unmut auf sich
gezogen etwa durch Straßenblockaden
spalten lassen will sich die
klima-bewegung aber nicht die letzte
Generation
radikaler als wir aber sie
fordert das richtige ich finde es sollte
halt am besten ohne Radikalität
im friedlichen Demonstrationen möglich
sein die Politik zu ändern ich glaube
dass ziviler Ungehorsam dringend geboten
ist unterstützt wurde Fridays for future
auch aus der Musikszene in München etwa
traten die Sportfreunde Stiller auf in
Berlin die Band juli in Hamburg Herbert
Grönemeyer und Silbermond
[Musik]
so das Wetter das gibt's gleich mit
Christa Orban um 22 Uhr das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers dann auch
mit ausführlichem Politbarometer das
war's in aller Kürze schönen Abend und
jetzt gleich weiter mit der zweiten
Halbzeit viel Spaß ihnen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend ein Wochenende voller
Spätsommer steht vor der Tür aber
morgens kann es durchaus kühl und auch
nie Blick sein wie heute Nacht vor allem
im Süden bei insgesamt 8 bis 15 Grad
aber tagsüber wird es noch mal warm 21
Grad an den Küsten und 28 Grad am Rhein
und dazu gibt es viel Sonne im Osten
bleibt das im Tagesverlauf auch so im
Westen und Südwesten werden die Wolken
aber dichter und abends gibt's dann
vielleicht auch mal einzelne Schauer
oder Gewitter am Sonntag ist es
ebenfalls warm mit etwas mehr Wolken
aber auch kaum Regen am Montag wird die
Wärme in den Osten verdrängt und dann
gibt es mit Gewittern spürbarer damit
auf Wiedersehen